hello my name is councilor Nigel Barker
and I'm the leader of Northeast Delta
District Council
I'm delighted to be speaking to you
today from the council officers here in
wingwood
we had plenty to be out and about but
the weather has dampened that idea he
keeps chucking it down as you all know
since May we now have a labor
Administration here at the council
during the next four years we'll be
working hard to follow up on our
Manifesto promises made during the
election campaign by tackling the issues
that matter to most of our residents we
are hitting the ground running with this
by successfully setting up a community
outreach service that offers tailored
one-to-one support to help you with your
finances help identify any benefits you
may be entitled to or signpost you to
mental health support more information
on the service can be found on our
website
our council plan is currently being
developed and is set to be completed
later this month setting out our aims
and Ambitions over the next four years
we'll let you know when it goes live so
keep a lookout on our website and social
media for updates last month I attended
the crashed event an event organized
with Partners in Clay Cross to highlight
the effects of alcohol as on young
people
and adults along with highlighting the
seriousness of drink and Drug driving
we have seen an increase in this
low-level anti-social Behavior which can
have a big impact on people's lives
and as you may know all I've read
already we are adding additional
resources to the community safety team
to tattle this
staying with a with Clay Cross there are
some exciting projects currently taking
place as part of the 24.1 million
claycross Town deal I'd like to update
you about this firstly if you attend
Charlie Park Leisure Center you will
have seen that the former Sports oil is
now just a shell with major construction
Works taking place on the car park and
the surrounding area
I'd like to thank you for all your
patience while these important words
take place
to bring you Clay Cross active a brand
new community Hub comprising a Leisure
Center Health provision and support
services set to open its doors in the
winter of 2024.
elsewhere within the glacross town deal
project
things are now moving into Pace
businesses are in the claycross town
deal boundary can now apply for grant
funding towards low carbon initiatives
such as renewable energy or waste
reduction
we are also seeking expressions of
interest for our new modern Town Center
units from Leisure and food and drink
businesses we also carried out a
consultation recently to hear people's
views on our town center regeneration
project following this we have now
submitted a planning application for the
development and they continue to work
with all our stakeholders to deliver the
best scheme for claycroft my final
mention for Clay Cross is about a survey
we are currently carrying out to find
out how residents connect with the local
community through everyday walking every
completed survey will be entered into a
prize draw to be in with a chance of
winning either a 10 pound 20 or 50 pound
Tesco voucher
chairland is one of the district's most
southerly Villages and has recently been
in the news here at Northeast Derbyshire
as we successfully prosecuted a suddenly
Nashville resident who didn't use a
licensed weight carrier and has
subsequently flighted their rubbish in
our district so we issued a 200 pound
fixed penalty notices as we have a zero
tolerance policy on flight tipping and
littering in our beautiful District
for further updates about Clay Cross and
much more about what we are doing to
improve the lives of everyone who lives
works and visits the whole of Northeast
Derbyshire can be found in our latest
magazine for residents called the news
there really is something for everyone
in this issue of the news from the
boredom busting activities we have for
children at our Leisure centers during
the six week holidays to the hidden gems
we have right across the district for
anyone wanting a fun day out
look out for it coming through your
letterbox or read it online on our
website
thank you for listening and I'll speak
to you again soon hopefully out and
about in The District in the meantime
please keep visiting our website social
media channels for all the latest
Northeast Derbyshire News and Views
thank you